Hola muy buenas noches Sí yo creo que En
definitiva lo que está ocurriendo con
los procesos judiciales es que no se
están realizando las investigaciones con
una dirigencia de vida y de acuerdo con
Los estándares Internacionales yo creo
que hay una cierta reticencia por parte
del sistema de justicia de perseguir la
responsabilidad de los agentes del
estado que cometieron las violaciones
los Derechos Humanos durante el
estallido y prueba de ello es la poca
cantidad de condenas que existen hasta
la fecha de hecho al día de hoy en el
informe que lanzamos actualmente hoy el
día de hoy damos cuenta de dieciséis
condenas pero actualmente las condenas
son 29 y la mayoría de ellas por delito
de apremio Legítimo
lo que a nivel internacional se conoce
como trato cruel inhumano degradante
pero no hay condena por ejemplo por
tortura siendo que fueron documentada
por varios informes de organismos
internacionales de Derechos Humanos
una amnistía Está alertando también de
la llamada ley de gatillo fácil aprobada
por el congreso que implica esta ley en
el actuar de la policía con el aumento
de la violencia en el país
efectivamente se aprobó en el congreso
lo que se llama técnicamente una ley que
lo que establece es una legítima defensa
privilegiada por parte de los
carabineros y para explicarlo de manera
sencilla lo que hace esa ley
derechamente es
rebajar los estándares
en relación con la posibilidad de que
los agentes policiales puedan invocar la
eximente de legítima defensa cuando
hacen uso de la fuerza en nuestra
opinión en mi opinión se trata de una
legislación que es demasiado amplia que
amplía demasiado la discrecionalidad de
los agentes policiales que no es
coherente con Los estándares
Internacionales sobre uso de la fuerza y
Por ende en nuestro
de acuerdo con nuestra posición es un
retroceso y no una base No contribuye
desde ningún punto de vista con la
garantía de la repetición
claro y se esperaba quizás que con la
llegada de un ejecutivo de izquierdas
cambiará este actuar de las fuerzas
públicas en que está fallando el
gobierno de borich en materia de
seguridad y del actuar de la policía
Bueno es lo que nos preguntamos es una
es una pregunta que habría que hacerle
al presidente de la república y a su
gobierno
lo que puedo señalarles quizás son
algunas inferencias yo creo que hay una
intención por parte del gobierno de
realizar avances lo que se refiere a las
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
ocurría durante el estallido social Pero
evidentemente el clima político que
actualmente rige en Chile No le favorece
el gobierno perdió dos elecciones la
elección de plebiscito sobre la nueva
constitución y ahora último la lección
sobre el nombramiento de los integrantes
del nuevo consejo constitucional en el
en la segunda versión del proceso
constitucional y en esa última elección
ganó la ultraderecha y por lo tanto yo
creo que el clima político no le
favorece pero de todas maneras lo que se
reclama en el informe que lanzamos hoy
día es que el estado debe implementar
una política pública de reparaciones
porque durante el estallido social se
cometieron gravísimas violaciones a los
derechos humanos de manera masiva y es
un deber Internacional del estado
cumplir con el derecho a la reparación
de las víctimas